يونيو 2014
في غضون ساعات مقاتلون ينتمون
إلى ما كان يعرف آنذاك بالدولة الإسلامية
في العراق وسيطرت سوريا
على ثاني
أكبر مدينة
في الموصل خلال شهر غيرت الجماعة
اسمها إلى الدولة الإسلامية
مما يشير إلى أن أطماعها العالمية أعلنت
عن ولادة جديدة.  الخلافة
وإعلان أبو بكر البغدادي خليفة لها
أو الخليفة مدينة تلو الأخرى
قبل سقوط قوات داعش الآن
بالأسلحة التي تم الاستيلاء عليها من الجيش العراقي المنهار
[موسيقى]
في أوجها كانت مملكة البغدادي
بحجم حكم بريطانيا
لملايين العراق  وسوريا ،
توافد الآلاف من الناس من جميع أنحاء العالم على الخلافة المعلنة من تلقاء نفسها
عبر وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي ، جذبتهم وعودها
بتنفيذ ما زعم تنظيم الدولة أنه
إرادة الله على الأرض ،
ما تلا ذلك كان كابوسًا لسفك الدماء
والدمار وأقليات
اضطهدت واستعبدت
ومقدسة.  كانت مواقع تدنيس
السادية والقتل الجماعي
أدوات أساسية لهذه الدولة
بعد ما يزيد قليلاً عن ثلاث سنوات  وكل
ما تغير من تنظيم الدولة
تم طرده من الموصل وفي الرقة في
سوريا ،
كانت عاصمتها الفعلية ستتبعها قريبًا
بحلول أوائل عام 2019 ، حيث
حوصرت بقايا التنظيم المتشدد
في زاوية نائية من شرق
سوريا بالقرب من الحدود مع العراق.
قصة معركة الخلافة
الأخيرة
ولكن ليس نقشها
[موسيقى]
بدأت المعركة النهائية بعد غروب الشمس
بقصف غارات التحالف الجوية على
آخر
نقطة على الخريطة التي تحتفظ بها الدولة التي
أطلقت على نفسها اسم
مدينة باجوزا فلكاني في شرق
سوريا
، كان من المتوقع  أن المعركة
الأخيرة ستستمر بضعة أيام فقط في الواقع
كنت على اتصال
بزميل صحفي آخر كان
هناك في
أواخر يناير ، وقال إنه من الأفضل لك الوصول
إلى هنا بسرعة وستنتهي في
غضون أربعة أو خمسة أيام
[موسيقى]
سوري  حققت القوى الديمقراطية تقدمًا جيدًا
داخل البلدة لكنها
تواجه بعض المقاومة من
مقاتلي داعش على الرغم من
الضربات الجوية المكثفة المستمرة للتحالف
على المدينة.
تقع المنطقة بجوار الحدود
مع العراق
على نهر الفرات ، لديك عربات اليد
التي تقع مباشرة على نهر الفرات على
الجانب الآخر من الفرات هي
النظام السوري ،
وهذا صحيح أن معظمهم من جميع
أنحاء العالم
كانت القوى الديمقراطية السورية  تشكلت
في أواخر عام 2015 وهم يقاتلون
أه داعش منذ ذلك الحين لذا فهو تحالف
من الأكراد
والعرب يقاتلون ضد داعش في
النهاية
كان عددًا صغيرًا جدًا
من الناحية النسبية لمقاتلي داعش ضد
القوة النارية المشتركة للولايات المتحدة
فرنسا وبريطانيا بالإضافة إلى القوات البرية
التي قدمتها القوات الديمقراطية السورية ،
كانت هناك محاولات متكررة للسيطرة على
البلدة
، وكان لا بد من وقف كل محاولة بعد
ثلاثة أو أربعة أيام
لإخراج المدنيين المدنيين الذين
سيأتون بالمئات وأحيانًا الآلاف
كل يوم.
وصلوا في شاحنات صغيرة ، كانت قذيفة مغبرة
مصدومة
ومرهقة وخائفة من إحضارهم
إلى
منطقة الاستقبال هذه التي كانت مجرد
بقعة غير موصوفة
في  السهول السورية شمال
نهر الفرات ، وصلت
درة أحمد البالغة من العمر 28 عامًا من تورنتو
كندا
إلى هذه البقعة القاحلة في السهول الشرقية الشاسعة
لسوريا ، حيث أتت إلى سوريا بناءً على طلب زوجها ،
ولم أكن أعرف شيئًا عن تنظيم الدولة أو
أي شيء قاله للتو.  انظر فقط
تعال
وشاهد غورا أحمد كانت أول امرأة تحدثت
معها خرجت من أراضي داعش
وتحدثت معها كان سرياليًا ،
أخبرتني أنها كانت تدرس
دراسات الشرق الأوسط في الجامعة لكنها
لم تسمع
بداعش وأنا أقول هذا  هل هذه هي
أخبار اليوم
في عام 2014 عندما غادرت كندا
وأتيت إلى سوريا ، كانت قصة داعش ضخمة
وكيف لا يمكنك
أن تعرف عنها ، فأنا أؤمن بالشريعة
أينما كان هذا القرف
تعرف هل يستحق ذلك؟
لا ، أنا أعلم وأخبرتها أنك
أتيت إلى منطقة حرب
لكنها لم تندم على موقفها هو
أنها سعيدة بالعيش حيث يتم
تطبيق
الشريعة وكان اقتراحها أن الشريعة الإسلامية
يتم تطبيقها بشكل صحيح لصالح داعش
لقد التقينا أيضًا
بمصممة الجرافيك السابقة البالغة من العمر 34 عامًا من
ألبرتا كندا
، والتي رفضت ذكر اسمها أو إظهار
وجهها ،
وأمرها زوجها بالمجيء إلى سوريا
، إنه أمر إلزامي بالنسبة لك أن
تأتي إلى هنا ليس لديك خيار
مثل ذلك  كزوجك هو مثل
أنا أقول لك أن تأتي إلى
هنا وكزوجة مسلمة
عليك أن تطيع رغم أنه كان من
الصعب
علي فعل ذلك ، كان علي
أن أكون أكثر صدقًا من الرجال.
لأن النساء بالطبع إما أنهن
لا يرغبن في ظهور وجوههن على
الكاميرا أو أنهن محجبات ،
فالكثير منهن كن
متشددات في حين أن الرجل الذي
تم الكشف عن وجهه بدا
أكثر ترددًا في التحدث بصراحة بالطريقة التي
فعلت بها النساء
ما  من الواضح أن المسؤولين قد
قللوا بشكل كبير من عدد
المدنيين في البلدة
خلال الأيام الثلاثة الماضية أكثر من
ألفي شخص
تركوا باروس في الواقع
وربما لا يزال هناك الآلاف داخلها
بينما ينتظرون نقلهم بالشاحنات إلى
مخيم للنازحين شمال هنا
لا يوجد قصف هناك
عطش جوع وبؤس
يصل الإمدادات. ذهبوا في ثوانٍ
يتدافع الأطفال في الغبار من أجل
قصاصات
[الموسيقى] [الموسيقى]
في أيام احتضارها معارك داعش حتى
النهاية المريرة  بلدة باروسيل سورية صغيرة نائية وغير ملحوظة
على ضفاف نهر الفرات
حيث حُصِرَت أخيرًا
إلى ظل وخز من
نفسها السابقة
بمزيج من
الجنود الأكراد والعرب المدعومين
بقوات خاصة بريطانية
وفرنسية وتحالف لا يلين  الضربات الجوية التي تم
التقاطها في هذا الفيديو الحصري الذي صوره
المصور المستقل
جبريل شايم قائد القوات الديمقراطية السورية
هافال
سمكو حارب تنظيم الدولة المعروف هنا باسم داعش
عبر
شمال سوريا
، أعتقد أن مقاتلي داعش على
المستوى العملي
كانوا يعلمون أن لديهم خيار
الاستسلام أو الاستشهاد  يموتون من أجل
القضية وأعتقد أن جزءًا منهم كانوا واقعيين
فهموا أنه لا توجد طريقة
لهذه المعركة
تنتهي بالنصر بالنسبة لهم ولكن كان
هناك آخرون بدا أنهم يريدون أن يموتوا
قتالًا يموتون كشهداء
ولكن أيضًا كان هناك من اعتقد
أنه بطريقة ما
في هذه اللحظة سيتدخل
الله إلى جانبهم ويهزم
الكفار الكفار  كما أطلقوا على الأكراد
والأمريكيين
والبريطانيين والفرنسيين ، فإن أيديولوجية داعش
هي لشيء واحد إعادة إنشاء
النظام السياسي الذي كان الإسلام في الأيام
الأولى للدين وأحد نقاط بيع
داعش هو أنهم سيعيدون
خلق  كيان لا يوجد فيه فساد
حيث يوجد
احترام لحقوق الإنسان في
سياق القرآن
وبطريقة ما يعيد تأسيس
هذا الكيان السياسي النقي ،
لقد كان مثيرًا للإعجاب في
البداية ولذا انجذب إليه الناس
ومن حيث الناس من الشرق الأوسط
كثير من أولئك الذين أصيبوا بخيبة
أمل من الربيع العربي
في عام 2011 رأوا الخلاص في هذا
الحل
المتطرف.  القسوة كانت مبنية
على اضطهاد أي شخص لا
يتفق مع
أفكارهم مما يعني أن المسيحيين
الأكراد الشيعة وبعض اليزيديين على
سبيل المثال
كانوا لا يعتبرون
كفارًا فحسب
بل وثنيين وكان تنظيم الدولة كما لو كانت دولة كابوسًا
يأخذها.  كان مطار الموصل في الحقيقة مجرد
خطوة أولى
الآن هذه القوات العراقية تتجه
إلى المدينة بشكل صحيح ،
كنت
متأثرًا لأن الجيش العراقي كان يستعيد تلك المدينة وما
رأيناه هو أنه عندما
خرج الناس من المناطق
التي يسيطر عليها تنظيم الدولة
كانوا سعداء
[موسيقى]
في هذه الحالة ، لديك بالتأكيد
انطباع
بأن هؤلاء الناس كانوا
يستسلمون على مضض بأنهم كانوا
يفضلون البقاء
ضمن أحضان الدولة الإسلامية
التي استوعبت أيديولوجية داعش
، فسألني ألا تعرف
آيات القرآن
التي تقول  ستواجه الدولة الإسلامية
مشقة
ثم ينصرها الله ،
كان هذا الصبي
الذي قابلناه للتو من إحدى هذه
الشاحنات التي تركت باروس
و  لقد تحدث بثقة
معينة لم أكن أتوقعها من صبي يبلغ من العمر 12 عامًا
يكاد يكون وقحًا بالطريقة التي نظر بها إليك
في وجهك ،
ما تركني في حيرة من
أمره هو مدى شعوره بالقوة والطريقة التي ولد
بها.  الحجج التي أعربت عنها داعش
ضد العالم وأكدت حقًا
فكرة أن
الهزيمة لا تعني نهاية تنظيم الدولة ، حيث
إن داعش موجودة في الداخل ، لذا فإن العديد من
الأشخاص الذين غادروا الأراضي
التي يسيطر عليها تنظيم الدولة
[الموسيقى]
يختبرنا الله هذه المرأة تقول ما
لا يستحق  سيغادر الصالحون
ويبقى الصالحون ،
فربما لا يستحقون
أنهم محاصرون فاق عددهم
ويتفوقون على
الهزيمة النهائية تبدو وشيكة ، لكنهم
يقاتلون على
قناعة ربما بأن
التدخل الإلهي سيسمح لهم بانتزاع
النصر من فكي الهزيمة.
محمد
الذي ينسب إلى مختلف الناس
ما
يقول أن المعركة الأخيرة بين
الإسلام وأروم مما يعني أن المسيحيين
كانوا سيقعون في بلدة تسمى
الضب.  إيك التي تقع بالقرب من الرقة في
جزء مختلف من سوريا
ولكن جيوش أروم المسيحيين
ستحيط بالمجموعة الأخيرة
من المسلمين الحقيقيين الذين سيكونون على
وشك الهزيمة ومن ثم
يتدخل
الله وينقذهم ويمنحهم النصر
الآن بالطبع.
لم يكن bahu dhabik ولكن الكثير منهم
يعتقدون
في أحلك ساعاتها ،
سيتم إنقاذ تنظيم الدولة فجأة من خلال
التدخل الإلهي الذي لم يحدث ، حيث
تعيش داعش برصاصة في
القنبلة وبالرصاصة في
الحظيرة تموت
[موسيقى
] يقود المنتصر
الأولاد والرجال المهزومون من ما يسمى
بالدولة الإسلامية الآن في أيدي
أعدائهم تم نقل
الآلاف من الرجال والنساء
والأطفال بالشاحنات من منطقة داعش
المنكوبة
ومن بينهم دوروثي مكاري زوجة عشيرة جان ميشيل
المرتبطة بإرهاب نوفمبر 2015
هجمات في باريس
أسفرت عن مقتل 130 شخصًا ، قام
زوجها بتأليف أغانٍ دينية تزعم أن
هذه كانت امرأة غاضبة
منا عندما تحدثنا إليها وتحدثنا
عن إراقة الدماء التي حدثت  داخل
عربات اليد
نتيجة القصف من قبل
الأمريكيين وشددت على الفرنسيين والبريطانيين
لا ، لا أريد العودة إلى فرنسا
أخبرتني لأن الدولة الفرنسية استخدمت
ذراعيها لقتل أطفالي
وزوجي وأنا أعلم إذا  أعود
، سأُسجن ، وقد كانت نموذجية لزوجات داعش
اللواتي بقين مخلصات لرسالته
لمهامه ،
هل تتمنى ألا تأتي إلى هنا ، سانا ،
فنلندية
اعتنقت الإسلام ، أتت إلى سوريا
منذ أربع سنوات مع زوجها
أ.  قالت سباكة مغربية إنني أريد
العودة إلى فنلندا الآن ، نعم
بالتأكيد بالتأكيد بالتأكيد على
الرغم من أنها أرادت الاستمرار في
عيش
حياتها كامرأة مسلمة ملتزمة بصرامة ،
نعم ، عادة
ما تتحدث الابنة باللغة الإنجليزية
بشكل جيد وكذلك الأم
ولكنهم أيضًا  لم يكن لدي أي شك في
عدالة
قضية داعش بأنهم ذهبوا
إلى سوريا ليعيشوا كمسلمين حقيقيين في
رأيهم ، لكني أدهشني هؤلاء الأشخاص
الذين جاؤوا
ليعيشوا هذا الخيال وهو
خيال ديني  على حساب كل
السوريين
الذين دمرت بلادهم
نتيجة هذه الحرب والحرب
ضد نظام بشار الأسد ،
كنا نتقدم إلى منطقة
أقرب إلى معسكر داعش
ولكن بسبب هذا
القتال  يبدو أن معركة قد
اندلعت معركة جديدة ،
لذا فنحن لن نذهب إلى أبعد من ذلك
بقدر ما يمكننا أن نذهب إليه ،
كنا في الواقع في طريقنا للذهاب
إلى جزء من معسكر داعش على حافة
باهرو الذي تم
تحريره من قبل  القوى الديمقراطية السورية
التي يمكن أن نسمع الكثير من
إطلاق النار هنا ، نحن قريبون
جدًا من الخطوط الأمامية ، كانت قوات سوريا الديمقراطية تمسك
يدًا كما
تعلم اثنين من الصحفيين في وقت واحد وكان
الجميع قد دخلوا وقالوا
إنه لم يكن هناك الكثير  لرؤية
الخيام والخنادق فقط
، ومن المفارقات أننا كنا آخر من دخلنا ،
وانطلق كل الجحيم ، يمكنك أن
ترى هنا
أن إطلاق النار يضرب
بالقرب منا لأن هناك قناصًا
في أحد مباني داعش ، أنت تعرف فقط
200 متر من  أين نحن كذلك إذا كنا
كان علينا الالتفاف حول
هذا الركن هنا ، سنكون معرضين لذلك
القناص ،
لذا وصلنا إلى هذا المنزل
واضطررنا للاختباء خلفه لأن
إطلاق النار كان كثيفًا
في الخارج ،
كنا هناك ربما 15 دقيقة ثم
قفزنا مرة أخرى على شاحنتنا الصغيرة
واحدة أخرى ،
حسنًا ، نحن في مكان جيد
وقدنا بأسرع ما يمكن خارج
تلك المنطقة ،
ما كان مثيرًا للاهتمام هو أنه بعد أقل من
ساعة من ذلك
بدأت المرحلة الثالثة والأخيرة من هذا
الهجوم
ثلاث مرات منذ أوائل فبراير / شباط ،
حيث شنت القوات الديمقراطية السورية
عمليات لإخماد الخلافة أخيرًا
ليلًا ونهارًا ، وقد قصفت طائرات التحالف التي تقودها قوات التحالف
بقذائف المدفعية والهاون
المخيم ،
ولكن خلال القوانين لا يزال من الممكن رؤية الناس.
يتجول التجوال عبر حطام
المباني التي يبدو أنها لم يمسها
القصف ،
هذا كل ما تبقى من
ما يسمى بالدولة الإسلامية التي كان يُخشى أن تكون شاسعة ذات يوم
كانت أراضيها  أصغر وأصغر ،
لذلك كان من الواضح في نقطة معينة
أن المعركة لا يمكن أن تستمر لفترة أطول
ولكن مع ذلك
أه حتى النهاية وما زالت
هناك مقاومة لا يزال هناك
مقاتلو داعش الذين كانوا سيقاتلون
حتى الموت
في  ذهبت الهزيمة هي التبجح
والغرور
في هزيمة رجال ما يسمى
بالدولة الإسلامية
ينحنون رؤوسهم ويغطيون وجوههم في
تناقض حاد مع
الانتصار الصارخ في الأيام الأولى لداعش
لم نتمكن من القتال بعد الآن ، لذلك
استسلمنا أحمد السوري يقول
هذا  كانت هذه هي المرة الأولى التي
تمكنت فيها من رؤية هؤلاء الأشخاص
يتحدثون إلى هؤلاء الأشخاص ، لذلك كان من
الرائع أن يكون
بعضهم عقلانيًا نوعًا ما بمعنى
أنهم حاولوا توضيح
أن مفهوم الدولة الإسلامية
كان مفهومًا جيدًا
للآخرين  مثل هذا الشاب الذي تحدثت إليه ،
فقد نشأ في مخيم اليرموك
للاجئين خارج دمشق
، أوضح أنه جاء
إلى داعش لأنه أراد أن يعيش حياة
لائقة
كمسلم ولم يفعل ذلك.  أي ندم على ذلك ،
ربما يحكم الأمريكيون العالم اليوم
كما يخبرني ،
لكن الله تعالى وعد المسلمين
أنه في
النهاية سيحكم الإسلام العالم في
نهاية المطاف ينتهي المقاتلون في
سلسلة من السجون التي أقيمت
في
شمال غرب سوريا.  من قبل القوى
الديمقراطية السورية وهناك أكثر من ألف من
هؤلاء الرجال
يأتون من خارج سوريا والعراق
ولا أحد يعرف ماذا يفعل بالمقاتلين الأجانب
لن تستعيدهم العديد من بلدانهم
ونقطة أخرى هي أن
القيادة الحالية لداعش
وعلى رأسهم أبو بكر
البغدادي ، أصبح الكثير منهم على
ما هم عليه اليوم
نتيجة الوقت الذي قضوه في السجن
والخطر هو أن هذه التجربة برمتها
ستتكرر مرة
أخرى الدولة التي يدعي الرجال أنهم يحكمون
باسمها.  من الله وطاعة النساء
على وشك الانقراض ،
ويدفع الأطفال والنساء الثمن وهم
يتدافعون على شاحنات تُستخدم عادة
لنقل الماشية
المتوجهة إلى المخيمات إلى منطقة لا.
rth نحن نشير إلى مخيم الحولة الذي يقع
خارج مدينة الحسكة ، ثلاث
ساعات
بالسيارة شمال باهرو
حيث كان هناك في ديسمبر 9000 شخص فقط
بحلول منتصف مارس كان هناك أكثر من 70000 شخص.
يتركز هؤلاء الأشخاص من داعش في هذا المعسكر الواحد ،
فإن فكرة إعادة تثقيف محاولة
التخلص من الراديكاليين
تكاد تكون مستحيلة نظرًا لأنهم جميعًا
يتركزون في منطقة واحدة
وبمعنى آخر ، فقد أعيد تشكيل الخلافة
في هذا المعسكر الأول  من شعارات داعش
في الإسلام العربي ،
كان هذا شعارًا في الكثير من
دعاية وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي الخاصة بهم على مقاطع الفيديو الخاصة بهم
وكانت الفكرة
هي أن داعش لا يمكن إيقافه
أنه لن يتم القضاء عليه أبدًا
وسيستمر في الانتشار
ولكن داعش كما هو  مفهوم ما زال حيا
في قلوب هؤلاء
الأطفال هؤلاء النساء هؤلاء الرجال الذين
خرجوا
وانتشروا في جميع أنحاء شمال سوريا
عاد عدة آلاف
إلى بلدانهم الأصلية
وذلك لأنه يعيش في
قلوبهم الإسلامية.  ستبقى دولة مرة أخرى في يوم من الأيام
وتنشر
[موسيقى]
لك